段ボールの落ちる音
はいというわけで今回はこちら
段ボールを110個準備しました
ィェーーーーーイ
今回この段ボールを使って何をしようかといいますと
それは
俺が
保育園の時だった
ロボットが大好きで
いつか自分で巨大なロボットを作ってみたい
そう思って気づいたら23歳でした
どうすればお手軽に巨大ロボットを作れるか僕は考えた末に思いついたのは
段ボールを繋げて頑張ってくっつければ
巨大ロボット作れるんじゃねぇかと思った訳なんですよ
はじめ）どうすか？
こちらの段ボール110個を繋げて
作ってみようと思います
で、作り方なんですけども
最終的には立たせたい訳よロボットを
そのまま作っても高いロボットは作れない
だから、まずはロボットを寝かせて作ります
寝てるロボットを作って
それを持ちあげたら
この静岡の街を彩ると
だから結構頑丈な段ボールなんで
段ボールでちゃんとくっつければちゃんと立つと思っております
では行こう！
まずは段ボールを並べていくところから始めていきましょう
付いてこい
あそこら辺に頭がいく予定です
こっちがもう片方の足
これがつま先
ポイでしょ
でもいい感じじゃね
かかとはちゃんと揃えないとね
足首が弱点になると思うんで
足首はちょっと補強していきます
4mの足ができました
次はまた股を作っていきます
まあ大体こんな感じでどんどん作っていく作戦でございます
ちょっと雨が降りそうで間に合わないので
今回のこのロボットプロジェクトに参加いただいて＆＄＆（’’
隊員の皆さんに手伝ってもらうことになりました
ありがとうございました
後はいけそうです
だいぶ終盤に差し掛かってきました
ロボットの見た目はほぼもう完成
後は頭をつけるだけです
という訳で全長約12mのロボットが完成しました
こちらです
（勇ましい音楽）
という訳でロボットが完成しましたので
早速起動させてみようと思います
オオォォォォ
立って初めて成功ですからロボットは
いきます！
あぁ～ダメかも
すまない皆　1人だと無理だったので
ここのオネェ....まさきを連れてもう一回チャレンジしてみます
いきます！
2人でも無理だったのでで3人でやろうと思います
キラーン
いきます！！
あーーー！
すいません　少人数だと無理な気がしてきたので
６人の人に手伝ってもらいます
腰と足に人を配置して
しっかり固定したまま体を起こしてみせます
では行こう
では行くゾーーー！！！！
行きます！
3,2,1
いける！いけるいけるいける
あ、足がつぶれ　あ、肩が肩が
足が足が
＊笑い＊
いけるいける
いやここまでは来れたんですけどね
残念なことに高さが足りないみたいです
とりあえずちょっと持ち上げてみましょう
せーのっ！
腕がーーー
＊吐息＊
あーーーーーーっ
＊崩壊＊
脚だけ立った
wwwwwww
あーー立ったーーー
大成功
（ED）